[Music]
6 26 on your monday morning how about
even more fun on las vegas boulevard
north of
sahara so in a town where there's no
shortage of things driving to crazy
we're getting more and more complaints
about the three-year-long project that's
got las vegas boulevard torn up from
spring mountain all the way up towards
charleston
now as we mentioned the strip between
sahara and spring mountain that is a
clark county project
today we're talking about the city of
las vegas throwing
another disruption into the mix north of
sahara
so starting today at the already
complicated intersection of las vegas
boulevard and
okie you won't be able to go west on
oaky potentially for the rest of the
month
if there's good news it said it's all
about repaving so maybe it'll get better
sooner rather than later
there and eastbound okay from the
boulevard is unaffected
now you can avoid all of this cone maze
which you probably want to do because
it's been driving you crazy
use maine instead of las vegas boulevard
and western instead of okie
by the way las vegas boulevard as you
know only one lane in each direction or
might seem like this has been going on
forever
the work actually started over a year
ago and it's got two more years to go
so buckle up drive carefully and please
put down that phone
if there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8
8newsnow.com